do you know who I am I have survived in
a world that does not want me when I
first came here from Germany I did not
even speak the language she's a very
clever and well-read woman but I fell in
love with this country it's passion she
loves a lot of things a lot of man full
expansion I'm for Empire
does he love anything apart from power
this machine likes mam she eats them
it's sounds like an interesting
proposition you are a very attractive
man only from the most beautiful woman
I've ever seen that is indeed a
compliment come up to my private
apartments you may do whatever it is you
think I want but I will not share my
throne with anyone
you are the empress and he can be your
devoted servant you think is as simple
as that men want power
I want what any man wants to make his
own way to find love the crown was never
heard by right Russia must be ruled by a
man
this is my country it would be a
terrible mistake to go against me
we love nobody but yourself I would like
to remind you that you owe all of your
advancement and all of your military
power to me I own you but I remind you I
waited to say Oh
I did what I did and I wouldn't have had
any of it any other way
you
you